you know greg's in medicine too larry oh
really yeah what feeling uh nursing
that's good
i've certainly been teased as like hey
[ __ ] or merce you're immersed i think
that came up and meet the parents some
at some point they're certainly gender
stereotypes related to different
professions hi gq my name is peter
glennon i'm an er nurse in new york city
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
er
let's go
[Music]
you know what she took i don't know she
just went into the medicine cabinet
we've got a lot of stuff around us
i have no idea what she has taken
julianna margulies character has come in
she's one of the ed nurses and she is
being treated for a drug overdose
certainly in real life her privacy would
be the utmost importance um just because
you work someplace doesn't mean any of
your rights are are diminished we take
patient uh privacy pretty seriously on a
drug screen right away two milligrams of
narcan and an amputee 50. you want a
pumper yep
the way he actually manages the patient
is appropriate he's going to give narcan
which is a reversal agent for opioids
that would certainly be ordered quickly
they get their talk screen they would
order that too because they'd want to
understand what a patient took who
possibly overdosed because it will
certainly map out what the treatment
plan would be for that patient the
narcan's given right away just in case
it's an opioid to try to reverse it as
you can have some respiratory depression
as a result of opioid overdoses so
excellent care by anthony edwards
is that a mistake repeat it twice
[Music]
dr edwards uh orders uh you talks and
they're looking to see what
if any drugs are within her system so
they see how they're able to treat what
the right treatment would be for her it
came back very very quickly 30 seconds
later it seemed like to me it would take
a bit longer where certainly the lab i
worked with one of the fastest ones in
the city but it would have probably been
about 10 minutes before that lab came
back they may have used a point of care
where they're able to do it in the er
the one i work in doesn't but
funny that it came back so quick and in
no way would nine to ten people surround
the case like that it would just be the
care team treating that patient julianna
margulies friend is there and she's
offering some information about what's
happening with the patient and it's
interesting that she's in there while
julianna morgles is getting treated but
it's important information it can really
direct the plan of care for that patient
so that's accurate if it meant getting
the information needed she would be in
the room with the docs and the nurses
while they're treating the patient
because the information she provides can
actually save
juliana's life so it's it's important to
to get as much information as possible
in an emergency situation like that meet
the parents
you know greg's in medicine too larry oh
really yeah what feeling uh nursing
that's good
uh no really uh what feeling
nursing
i've certainly been teased as like hey
focker or merce you're immersed i think
that came up and meet the parents
there's certainly
gender
stereotypes related to different
professions nursing certainly i think
people at one time
thought of only women in that role i
think that's completely changed in in
the in the last number of years there's
a lot more male nurses out there than
there were
10 years ago certainly the profession is
majority women but more and more men are
turning to nurses as a career and i
think that's super exciting the more
diverse
the better i mean in all things i wanted
to keep my options open but in the end
nursing was just a better fit for me it
gives you the freedom to work in several
different areas of medicine plus i can
focus 100 on patient care as opposed to
being a doctor where you have to deal
with bureaucracy oh
i can relate often the question you get
asked as a as a nurse is why didn't you
become a doctor and my answer typically
is because i didn't want it greg's
talking about his passion for patient
care and i think that certainly is a
common thread through all nurses whether
the emergency department or in the icu
or on the medical surgical floor it's a
different connection to the patient than
a provider has it's a certainly a
special one it is certainly a calling
you really have to have that empathy and
desire to aid in the healing process to
be a nurse it's something that always
spoke to me i was actually a paramedic i
would drop patients off at one of the
emergency rooms in my area that i worked
and there was a there was a guy who was
the triage nurse and he was super cool
guy
and he would he had his white jeans on
every day and this his cool shirt like
hawaiian almost shirts they had no dress
code at this hospital i guess but the
way he interacted with patients was just
so warm and he was so smart and he
always knew what to do and knew what
they needed that it inspired me to
to to become a nurse actually i saw some
representation there that i could
identify with and i wanted to be like
him the upside
done
young merlin's got the sword
so that would make my penis the stone
then
can you stop saying that word just using
your analogy stop saying the word i'm
asking you
it's not helping me okay
all right so i'll take this out
and then i um
i got a pinch to pinch the head
put it in
all right we see patients present
occasionally with urinary retention and
this is a very painful condition and if
left untreated can really cause damage
to the bladder bacterial infections and
in late stages of it kidney failure so
us having the ability to place a
catheter is super important it one
provides relief for the patient and also
can avoid those complications once that
catheter is placed clearly kevin hart is
not a registered nurse based on his
performance here placing a urinary
catheter is a very serious procedure
that can
if not done appropriately cause
infection so there's a lot of
preparation done to ensure that it's a
sterile procedure also a a registered
nurse or a doctor or anyone in the the
healthcare field would respect this
patient's uh anatomy more appropriately
and and make them comfortable and not
have this kind of banter he's removing
the catheter um and then it seems like
he's about to put it in back in but he's
not utilizing he's not creating a
sterile field his hands are everywhere
we would create a sterile field wear
sterile gloves it's a very thorough
process to apply them as to maintain
that sterility um and that it takes some
time and we actually do it with another
nurse to ensure that they
can can verify that we actually did
maintain sterility before putting a
catheter in nurse jackie i know you
i just had to sit there and look that
kid's mother in the eye and tell her
that we did everything we could you dumb
[ __ ] that was my patient i told you he
was slipping and he was
i tell you to order a scan you order a
goddamn scan because if you don't do it
i'll just go to the next doctor and the
next doctor after that in the meantime
that kid died it's just so out of the
realm of reality that would happen in a
hospital there's so many things um wrong
with that scene if she had a concern
about care that would have been
addressed in real time and she would
have escalated and gotten resources to
to assist her a conversation like that
they were having i would immediately
want an hr person to come yeah that man
wouldn't work in a hospital now
house
thank you for joining me for tonight's
dress rehearsal playing the part of andy
is morty randolph for his donation to
science we give our thanks
once andy is cool and goes off bypass we
have 60 seconds to get two liters of
blood out of her body back into her
pictures to find the clot in her head in
the ed we're certainly not doing it on
um a cadaver but we do practice a lot
and as you know new nurses we spend a
lot of time in a sim lab where we use
pretty some advanced robotics that mimic
different
situations whether it's a patient the
way to manage them lowering their blood
their blood pressure is really low or
they're having difficulty breathing most
recently we set up some sim where i work
to handle an imminent delivery of a baby
which happens in the ed occasionally so
it's such an incredible way to learn you
certainly need to read the book on how
to treat a patient but actually going
through the muscle memory of it and the
physicality of it is pretty incredible
and such a great resource for both the
person who works in a hospital or a
registered nurse or a doctor but also
what that means for the patient the
great skill set that someone can develop
using simulation like that certainly a
surgeon or a doctor or a mid-level
provider potentially would do skills on
a cadaver that definitely happens
sorry how hard can this be it's a little
busy down here again
if we didn't have to levade your gastro
again
again
you should be able to hear a pin drop in
that room it's it's usually really quiet
usually the provider that's leading
needs to be able to direct different
folks to do different things whether
it's give meds or provide respiratory
support so it's really important that
only the right people are there and that
there's a state of calm um in that
environment so
we can hear each other and that nothing
is critically missed it's really
something amazing to behold it's almost
like a symphony um the way
people work together in an environment
like that it's a really
impressive thing grey's anatomy
cassidy the doctor said the labs in
imaging showed an eight-week pregnancy
so you're all clear
okay so that's it it's just the pill two
pills actually you'll take one
medication now to block the hormones
that keep the pregnancy viable then a
second pill in 24 hours to help contract
the uterus
you'll feel nauseated and crampy
probably emotional because hormones
she's giving a great summary of what the
medication does and so great job by the
nurse in that scene i haven't watched
grey's in a bit but you know it's on
season 47 at this point in the first few
seasons you would they really
under-utilized or under-represented the
scope of practice of a registered nurse
you see a lot of
them doing sort of like cleaning tasks
which are certainly important in a
hospital setting but they don't really
demonstrate really what a nurse does in
terms of the knowledge base they have
the monitoring the the clinical skills
in terms of like assessment and showing
what the status of a patient is and how
important their role
is in identifying problems that may
arise with a patient in a hospital
setting they are sort of these like uh i
don't know ancillary characters on in
these shows sometimes it really just
doesn't show like their their true
nature in the hospital setting mesh
this one's in needs hemorrhaging you
need a whole blood stat come on take him
okay it's his leg do a sterile prep move
it hurry
at this chest he's in pain ms one
quarter he'll be next to no war come on
move it move it we've got more coming
so we see major houlihan uh triaging
patients which was completely
appropriate she's doing what they call a
gestalt assessment which is just really
trying to rapidly understand what's
going on with the patient and what kind
of care they're gonna need certainly
i've never seen a triage nurse in a
wedding dress at work but you know the
process is important it's you have to
understand and make a quick judgment
about what's going on with the patient
and get them the care they need what's
her accuracy rate i couldn't tell yet
but i i think her judgment in the
setting that it is she's probably
getting those folks the best care
possible in the emergency department we
do a lot of planning around
multi-casualty incidents we call them
mcis and there's a lot of algorithms on
how to manage a high volume of patients
that would appear suddenly it's all
about resource utilization and how do we
use our resources to best treat the
largest amount of people so we certainly
would classify
the
extent of an injury or
whatever is happening with that patient
and and try to timely get the people who
need the care the fastest to get that
care and if there are folks that
potentially could wait a bit we're
certainly going to prioritize the the
severity of the the injury pearl harbor
right here
don't touch me you jeff get your whole
tall thing critical get him into
critical him
critical for lord
how
sad am i you're gonna be just fine
sweetheart
[Applause]
it's very important that we not mix
patients up when so many of them come at
the same time you know where i work we
actually have built an algorithm called
mci the first hour
to
ensure
that when faced with something like that
you have the necessary tools and you
prioritize your resources to get the
victims of of a situation like that the
best possible help we can possibly give
them we see
kate beckinsdale she's she's running
around she's trying to triage as many
patients as possible she's using her
lipstick and you see she writes the c on
one patient they're critical they need
to get care right away they're going to
go right in and see the doc and then
sadly she writes an f on another patient
she has made the assessment that they
are too far gone for care and that they
unfortunately will expire uh in the in
the near future and that they would be a
drain on resources in real life now in
2021 most mcis where there's a big uh
there's a lot of casualties they use a
start triage system and that is a way
for
pre-hospital folks who who care for
patients in the field to tag different
patients with different categories and
you know they're looking at what's the
mental status of the patient what's
their respiratory status how's their
circulation are they bleeding do they
have any significant injuries and they
will tag will actually tie a tag to to
folks in an mci in those different
categories some sadly if they're
deceased or if they have minor care
sometimes just a minor cut or bruise
needs to get assessed they'll check that
out so they'll have a green tag there's
also a yellow one that means delayed
they are not in an urgent need to get
care right away but they did but they
may have a an injury or something
happening with them and then you get to
critical a red tag and that means that
that patient really requires rapid
intervention kate beckinsdale grabs her
stalking and i think she's using it as a
tourniquet fortunately we don't need to
do things like that one it's a huge
infection control problem and two in the
hospital setting we don't need to
macgyver things we have what we need we
understand the tools we train on those
specific types of tools i have never
really seen too much macgyvering because
you want to use equipment in a way
that's really safe for a patient so it's
important to utilize the appropriate
tools at the appropriate time in the
appropriate way john q
all right
done
with that pressure up pressure up
[Music]
when you're in a hospital setting the
use of a defibrillator would be so
accessible there would be no reason for
him to do that tap on the heart
certainly we we don't recommend people
punching people in the chest the current
recommendation is you would always go
for a defibrillator so that wouldn't
happen in today's world staff
certainly their safety is paramount so
if there was a hostage situations many
hospitals have different codes with a
color coordinated for a hostage we would
have a specific color that the staff
would be educated on and there would be
an announcement through the building if
god forbid there was a hostage situation
dr death
this isn't right
no it isn't we gotta run stat h you need
to say something
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] should we start the cell saver
doctor focus on your job as a nurse your
your job is to advocate for your patient
whether they're awake or
undergoing surgery so there wouldn't be
this shyness when the situation isn't
safe that's our duty the culture i work
in
really encourages uh someone a team
member to speak up and despite hierarchy
or what your role is and that really
that kind of culture serves the patient
there's a lot of bleeding doctor we
should get an a-line kit 14-gauge iv
blood warmer maybe give us you a heads
up
and we have an algorithm we would follow
so if we feel like something isn't going
well we wanna first voice our concern be
like hey guys i'm really concerned about
this and then if there's no response to
that concern then we're gonna yell
you know i'm uncomfortable with this and
then lastly this feels unsafe
and so we all say that to each other as
a team always it's certainly where i
worked at first i'm concerned we would
all just stop what we were doing um to
have a conversation if we feel like the
whatever's happening isn't the right
course of action we're the patient
advocate so we want to make sure that
the patient's getting uh the best
possible care we gotta get this under
control doctor we
you mean me i need to get this under
control yes doctor you need to get this
under control perhaps we bring in
vascular what's vascular going to do
when you can't get the blood pressure
under control it's not an issue with the
blood pressure why don't we start there
shall we
[Music]
see the disc what is blood doing for us
it's it's providing oxygenation to the
body so if you know it's leaking out all
over the floor it's certainly concerning
we can exist with some blood loss but at
a certain point we wouldn't be able to
maintain life so he's worried he feels
like that's too much blood loss and the
the surgeon in this scene doesn't seem
to be concerned or is willing to play
with how much he can actually lose
without causing uh harm certainly you
know the docs i work with this would
never happen just you know this is
definitely one for a movie or a tv show
the nick
christ the bullets lodged in the tunica
it's the only reason he hasn't already
bled to death
do you really think we'll be able to
save this late
i'm not even sure we can save the man
if someone has a leg injury like that we
in the er are gonna stabilize that leg
um and depending if you're you know
there's different types of er some are
trauma centers some aren't different
kinds of ers can handle different types
of emergencies that guy definitely would
have needed a trauma center for a
gunshot to the leg because it requires
special kinds of surgery so we would
stabilize that patient and we would get
them to a trauma center within the
trauma center they would be stabilizing
the ed and be sent right up to the or
for treatment
you need to take the leg off now
it's already showing signs of necrosis
can't get the
broken bones to set
this pulse is eccentric we need to
amputate now
amputation definitely not an er
uh procedure certain types of cancers
today today and trauma could require
some amputation that's a thorough
thorough process and
a lot of specialists would have to weigh
in on to make a decision like that for a
patient with the patient the gentleman
is
trying to irrigate the wound for him
using a giant syringe i guess with which
is like salt water it's the same
osmolarity of blood and he's trying to
clean the wound today we would certainly
use sterile water or saline
that patient probably with all the
fingers and such going into his leg
probably would get a nasty infection
that poor man and his leg i certainly
sympathize for him thanks so much for
watching these clips with me i hope you
learned something until next time